si la ve tattoo heures de son état il
représente 10 ont l'âme populaire de
fort dauphin le tatouage est une
création personnelle
la machine aussi ça c'est du plastique
et le portemine la tête pour porter
l'échiquier le pont l'interrupteur
locales et les chargeurs de téléphones
motorola donc et faute de mieux on fait
avec les moyens de bord quand le jeune
homme cumule les petits boulots pour
s'en sortir
et pourtant au menu de chacun de ces
repas seulement un peu de riz
moi par exemple la menthe nico clé pour
toute la journée
le repas du midi on laisse la moitié
fait le monde le soir et c'est pas que
je profite encore pas mais c'est la
nécessité qui oblige
[Musique]
fort dauphin est restée la même pendant
des décennies un peu endormi et un beau
jour
rio tinto un groupe anglo australien
déjà présent dans 50 pays s'est installé
à quelques kilomètres de la ville
il a créé une filiale malgache appelé
qmm pour commencer l'exploitation d'une
mine gigantesque pendant deux ans les
travaux autour de la mine ont amené une
activité frénétique hôtels restaurants
et voitures neuves ont poussé comme des
champignons et il y avait aussi la
promesse de rénover la ville entièrement
les habitants devaient pouvoir profiter
des installations top moderne de qmm
hôpital électricité eau courante
déception normalement toutes les routes
sont la ville devait être fait
il y en a qui se sont fait un peu on
périphériques surtout mettons le
centre-ville de bain comme là ça fait
cinq ans qu'on a ce truc là et avec les
grosses pluies par moyens de passer
les investissements massifs de la mine
ne bénéficie qu'aux employés de qmm ou
des sous-traitants
on a eu deux trois trottoirs qui ont été
faits quelques méthodes de route mais
c'est pas mon faible et ça ne tombe pas
des sous à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et ça
ne donne pas de travail aussi pour les
plus pauvres
la grande entreprise reste un rêve
intouchable et là ça va ce travail n'est
pas fait pour aînés on a des enfants
tout petit on n'a pas les moyens de
prendre des noues du maintien de la paix
ainsi quand il ya un client oppose notre
enfant et on le sert mais vous ne voulez
pas travailler là bas si l'on donne du
boulot on veut bien travailler là bas
pourtant si la ve le tatoueur tout ce
que tu aimes m a amené par ailleurs
n'est que de la poudre aux yeux
[Musique]
ils se sont dit on s'en fout
si on arrive à les rendre assez content
fait trois trucs comme ils sont ils sont
pas des grandes connaissances ils vont
même pas s'en apercevoir
là où il ya des milliards à amasser des
fanfares mon cas de conscience des sous
il est
il est en flammes de la conscience